Bruce tim's art just had such huge
impact on people because it was just so
different so new there's a language of
line work that was unlike anything
people had seen at the time
DC animation just really kind of
exploding expanded it was a huge
inspiration the designs the storytelling
even the animation it's just so unique
the representations on the show were
everything that you loved about the
comic it gave a whole generation Batman
Superman Wonder Woman to know and to
love
[Music]
line work and silhouettes no matter
which angle it's Tirana net you could
see in the show that it creates a sense
of movement so we wanted to kind of
capture that energy and bring that
energy into a three-dimensional form
that's representative of the feeling of
the cartoon we're starting the line with
Batman Superman and Wonder Woman and
with DC we always default to the Justice
League Trinity because it covers so much
we didn't want a static presentation we
really wanted something that not only
captured the style but captured the
animation it's kind of meant to embody
the best attributes of each character
translating any 2d art especially art
that fans hold really dear turning that
into 3d is always a challenge
[Music]
you always have to check your lines from
every single angle every step of the way
because one contour from the front it
looks totally different when translated
in a 3d from a different angle
during the show the style started to
change and we just wanted to take bits
and pieces of everything and make the
idealized version of Batman Superman and
Wonder Woman
[Music]
we're just doing a little highlighting
and shading to sort of give them a more
three-dimensional feel but I think from
any angle you could take a picture of it
and it would look like a still from the
show we wanted the basis to be very
specific to that character in their
storyline much more representative of
the backgrounds in the show splattered
and stipple II kind of creating tonal
maps and shadows rather than more subtle
paint on the figure I think we've taken
the art and found a fun new unique way
to present it
the collaboration aspect on these things
is it's amazing
[Music]
pretty much everyone involved has an
intense love for these characters
I'm hopeful and optimistic that our fans
will find the joy in these things as
much as we have
[Music]
the sense of action I think it's really
what ties them all together
it's been great watching the main
Trinity kind of come to life
but I think fans will be excited to see
which characters outside of the Trinity
may be coming up
[Music]
you